[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
John
hey Erica oh I almost didn't recognize
dude I mean you look good I lost her a
little weak okay thank you you know you
just miss the reunion last week right
how was it yeah I'm not going back to
another like 15 years everybody was
either married or engaged or engaged to
be engaged my favorite by the time I go
back everybody be on their second
marriages and divorces that laughs me
that's when I'll make my move yeah Oh
actually I am running late for therapy
but do some good running into you yeah
we should hang out I'd love that yeah
you know and DaSilva know she's having a
Halloween party this Saturday there's
gonna be a ton of Polytech people there
you should come oh I I think I have a
friend's thing but oh okay it was like I
was awesome bumping into John oh this is
great you look great this was great uh
enjoy your friend thing yeah actually uh
Erica yeah um I'd love to go to your
thing on Saturday okay well then I'll I
choked okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm sure this loves a party she survived
[Music]
we went to high school together
in Chicago right
that's very nine beans guess my
customers [ __ ] power [ __ ] power
yeah no luck in town you know it's like
salt in my game
go find your man okay come on let's go
you go all right we'll see ya but I
wanna be supportive because she just got
divorced and I mean are your parents
together no no okay yeah I mean it's
just I wanna support her but I don't
think my mom [ __ ] sure no no no
you're you're good
Jim horn Boyle uh okay she's uh she's a
friend from way back oh yeah no good I I
don't drink actually okay responsible
manager
[Music]
Lauren
or boil
John qual we went to Polytech yeah yeah
hey man how you doing good how you doing
great great do you live in Los Angeles
yes do you I do walk do I haven't seen
you in like a decade
yeah it's no aisle that's pretty earth
right yeah it's great bumping into you
yeah you too good see ya yeah
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody why are you panting this
doesn't breathe at all it's like I could
imagine
come on
the [ __ ] are you doing it I just had to
answer some emails okay well we've just
came in here to talk [ __ ] [ __ ] outside
[Music]
little right in here
I think these are the drapes okay thank
you hold on
[Music]
she can't okay so they were shirt on
okay we don't have to do this week
that's totally fine it's fine it's okay
I just yeah I just I see you a minute
oh yeah no I'm sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah have you seen a girl like a cat
costume
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi
Hey
she really don't member me do you
I remember we went to high school
together
chod what John Cho used to call me chode
oh I guess we had pretty stupid names
for friends in high school we weren't
friends okay
it was high school I don't I don't know
what you want from me like you still
hung up on pictures of me on the
Internet
that bastard we didn't make fun of you
because we were fat Charlie come he is
was fat he didn't have an issue with it
he was like popular he had a girlfriend
Charlie Cummings was a drug dealer
I just want to get a rise out of you why
would you do that I don't know because
you made it really easy dude you let
everybody get under your skin
you shouldn't take it so hard I did the
mission your school because you were so
[ __ ] awful to me I'm pretty sure you
missed a year of school because you
pulled the fire alarm during why your
meltdowns that's not my fault I had a
list of the middle school and people
made fun of me for that just what I have
a list anymore and you look great
so maybe all the teasing worked out huh
you're a bad person okay do you want my
advice
put it behind you because you look great
[ __ ] you
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's up Erica
[Music]